what up
I'm going to just link to this in this
bar
it's not worth tweeting about you guys
you guys know the discord let's go right
here
give a little bit of time for some
people to get in here I got two things
to show you today it's gonna be quick
livestream puts up box or hello Logan
Legrand welcome to everybody close the
doors in my office take off her hoodie
welcome welcome welcome so we have one
question to ask today and that's our FCA
people better than Subaru people so wait
why is this not here let's see is it
live oh yes it is
oho FC a car honest if you right now go
to our shop you can buy one of these
guys this is a harness it supports we're
gonna go through all the cars that it
supports it supports the chrysler
pacifica it supports the chrysler
pacifica it supports the chrysler
pacifica hybrid all of these are
supported by you know things like this
this is the bosch one i'm sorry tonight
i've fun and then where's the Jeep at
yeah it also supports the jeep grand
cherokee so you can buy you can buy an
FCA harness put this in your chrysler
pacifica and be just like way mom you
can you can you can be just like way moe
um it's not more car ports what we're
doing is we're consolidating everything
a comma is about stability is about ease
of use is about making this stuff
consumer friendly that's the word
consumer friendly that's right so it's
very easy for you to install this it's
completely behind the trim this is the
first harness we've had to do can you
buy a car with Eon on it no we don't
sell cars this is the first harness
we've had to do a little bit differently
so you see these ones are just straight
up wire harnesses
unfortunately the female FCA connector
and actually we should make sure let's
make sure just the harness connector
[Music]
connector perfect you can buy FCA
harness connectors to only $50 this is
really in the same deal because it
includes two parts it includes both this
wiring harness part and this little
adapter board which goes from this what
is that 12 pin molex to this FCA female
and you see the FCA female fits into the
FCA male beautifully can you buy a car
and put me on it then sell me no no no
no no this isn't for you man this isn't
for you
this is a chill livestream I'm gonna
tweet about it no tweet about the
livestream it's chill just for the
discord grows we got something else to
show you too but we're only gonna show
to you if at least one person buys the
FCA harness we need one person oh you
know what we're gonna we're gonna add
everyone maybe they will just do any
announcements channel FCA artist is live
you want to try open pilot is there any
help no there's not any help there's no
help no there's help you can come on
this cord but if you're not technical
it's not for you when you can try right
but but open pilot is give and take
right open pile it's not just like if
you think you're gonna like fire like an
apple watch and just install it not
another now if you're willing to put the
time in you get something before
everybody else in the world like this
beautiful FCI harness so we just need to
wait for a few people to get in here
we need to sell one of these it's gonna
get easier it's always gonna get easier
but you know if you're asking those kind
of questions those are all kind of
questions there's always help off on
diskless fcj harness is live yeah we're
at the kebab shop now and I think of Bob
Sheppard is right around the corner
though makes great kebabs FCA harnessed
there isn't really that much more to say
about it
we also fire tweet today exactly yeah
somebody sent them an overpriced car
that sounds like the right solution here
40 more people come one come all to this
absolutely chill don't tweet about it
stream where we launch the FCI harness
and we figure out once and for all if f
seiei people are better than super
people all right
maybe when we get to 50 people I'll show
you guys the cool thing so let's talk
about upcoming features I know new
features ever that's right all features
are canceled that's a lie
we launched the FCA harness the Hyundai
harness coming soon and if you want to
get one of these FCA harnesses you got
three days you got three days to come
down to our virtual store at shop , da
di and buy it if you want to get it
fulfilled before the holiday break give
your loved one hours of entertainment
buy them an eon of what this does is it
allows you to plug in your chrysler
pacifica or your jeep compass I think we
also support one more car don't forget
open pilot
soon to yem like maps yeah no no maps
are never gonna happen
maps a lie you see we've updated the
readme we've included limitations be
sure to read these very carefully like
you read your car owner manual and we
push some cars into community maintain
cars and features but fortunately the
Chrysler's are right here in officially
supported cars the jeeps are right here
and officially supported cars because
actually a lot more to get what you mean
red lights and stop signs like this like
whoa is that it's that open pilot
running on it on a PC look at that model
detecting that lane look at that oh yeah
we support Kia Kia's are just you and
eyes yeah open pilot in simulation you
want to talk about features look at that
this is just a computer that's manager
running entirely on a computer will fix
the slow frame thing this is real this
is very real
um this is Carla so uh yeah yeah we're
gonna make open pilot run in well now
it's an internal fork for now but we're
gonna make open pilot run in simulation
this is a big push for next year so
everybody can develop with open pilot
not just people who have the supported
cars we got some absolutely crazy
announcements lined up for 2020
FCA harnesses are just the start do we
need a do you need a GPU there's running
the CPU right now not kind of under the
CPU we got we got some great read you
some great research from from from the
research team let's see if we sell any
FCA harnesses you know the amount of
leaks that I want to give has a lot to
do with how much FCA harnesses we sell
and so far there's been zero FCA harness
is stalled
so we got I'll show you I never want to
show you user stuff but that's what's
happening with our store today so you
know we got to get this number we got to
get this number up we got to go way way
up
open pilot unfortunately we can't move
yet oh if you already have the hub um if
you already bought the harness you can
go right in here and you can just buy
the harness connector we sell them for
50 dollars Subaru is right now
equivalent to FCA nobody bought any
Subaru harnesses either I think we
filled six of them so far but I believe
in you FTA people come by come by
FCA yeah yeah look it's about simulation
all right all right
your your your no no no this is the
wrong kind of questions to ask I don't
know if it's legal I'm not a lawyer man
you got it you got it you got to ask
your friendly neighborhood lawyer about
that
FCA harness buy it right now $50 if you
want the black panda which you
definitely do want the black Panda yeah
simulated car that's that's what I'm
talking about
can I Drive a simulated car I'm not sure
I don't think I wrote any of that maybe
we can do a coding livestream later
where we write some of that code but um
whoa whoa oh no I thought we got an
order I got excited about the forbidden
topic if it's demonstratively safe and
time there's a lot of forbidden topics
I'll let you mention one word of it
which which which forbidden topic if
it's torque interceptors no oh don't
know okay look torque interceptors look
there's less safe things in the world
than to work interceptors if you truly
have built a torque interceptor that is
as LD and applies the limits and meets
all automotive standards I think you can
build a safe torque interceptor but I
think that the the bar to do it is
really beyond a hobbyist project so if
you guys are like a company and you're
building torque interceptors and like
you know you put a lot of resources into
Q&A into testing then I do think torque
interceptors are possible but I think
that an open-source torque interceptor
like the way the pedal is open-source is
extremely dangerous this is the worst
case law if your pedal freaks out the
worst thing that happens is your car you
get uncontrollable acceleration go into
neutral step on the brake you're fine
uncontrollable steering torque a sazzle
d yeah you gotta you know commas for
people who are gonna who are gonna
search and find come on FTA people can
we sell one of these things you guys
make me never want to introduce new
harnesses you guys make me realize that
the only car anybody cares about is
Honda's employerís
um you think some of it can be
deconstructed to be given the control
method how and what do you mean by
deconstructed
if you're straight-up intercepting the
torque sensor on power steering I don't
see how that's not D because of
malfunctioning you're thinking cause ah
mmm beautiful all right we got four
visitors right now on the store let's
see the live view or any you guys buying
an f CI harness I just wanna I just want
to conclude this video with the
conclusion that f seiei people are
better than Subaru people we can leave
it there oh oh we got we got a person
there where are these other visitors
since it's harder to control the motor
it's less likely for a catastrophic
killer
you know what how about this before you
post a safety analysis post like an ISO
- six - six - safety analysis of a
torque interceptor and we're happy to
comment on it um this isn't about remote
control a lot live remote control is
absolutely banned well what what what
what could you possibly be doing good
with a remote control
at least the torque intercept for like
torque interceptors have positive value
- right
yeah flexing exactly thumbs down thumbs
down right well we gave up safety so we
could flex thumbs down Oh Kevin wants a
diagram right
0:06 visitors right now oh oh oh come on
come on somebody buy one somebody buy
one oh you know you want to buy one
they're beautiful they're they're FCA
harnesses they're only $50 399 when
coupled with a brand-new black panda
that has integrated GPS I don't have one
of my desk I'll have is on my desk isn't
yawn oh boy we just sell what do we just
sell was that an SCA harness I'm going
to check I'm gonna check
up oh yeah if you announce your name on
the stream I will confirm that it was
you who purchased an FBI harness thank
you we have absolutely proven that FCA
people are better than Subaru people
thank you for buying you guys give me
hope you guys give me hope of launching
harnesses now spill okay okay okay you
want a leak will show you a leak this is
the research teams leak but let me see
if I can find it okay what no no no no
no what oh no I don't know anything
about it oh no we don't have any looks
um but we do have this joint model oh
yes oh this see these end-to-end
longitudinal you see this integrated
pose net yeah and you see how the curves
are beautifully sloping down the models
the deep is learning oh it's beautiful
oh look at that yeah
I'm the other leak which I'm sure many
you guys have already found is um it's
not so hard to enable automatic lane
changes but we haven't officially
shipped automatically in changes it's
not shipped and do remember that the
automatic lane change does not check the
blind spot so that is always your job
yeah it's good enough the problem with
red light two stop signs is not the
camera red lights and stop signs are
hard for a whole different set of
reasons but this stuff man
end-to-end longitudinal control that's
one of the things I'm really excited for
in 2020 in addition you guys have seen
hopefully in zero 7 vo ATC I think it's
no radar right so in zero 6 - we
switched I know 20/20 is near that's
right um in zero 6 - we switched from
the radar being the primary sensor to
vision being the primary sensor um you
tried to take the lane change into a
curb and it was ready to go it'll tell
you yeah if you turn the blinker on
it'll still tell you um it shouldn't
actually make the lane change but again
that feature is not officially shipped
we did leave the skeleton in there for
it so you guys can can can mess around
and start experimenting with it was the
biggest harness purchase we sold a lot I
think I think Taiwan there's a bunch of
people in Taiwan really buy a lot of
these things in big quantities we get
another FC a harness or am I being too
greedy it's really a beautiful harness
comes with these tiny boards reading
these speed limit signs
these sound like community features
community features you guys can write
that stuff we've opened sort of like all
of open pilot is open source now it
should be relatively easy for you guys
to add a something else that runs the
model bro shop is slow take a look
you're this close to getting banned I
don't know what to tell you man you use
dial-up does it make does it make a mean
noise when you connect to the internet
well maybe that's why it's slow what
else we got
when is autopilot when is open pile for
PC gonna be released was been my pet
project sometime in in 2020 San Diego is
a beautiful place you know they say it's
always sunny in philadelphia this ally
of been to Philadelphia but San Diego's
pretty close when open pilot for the
Xbox 360
Oh way better in the Bay Area yes we
sell one more FCA harness what's our B
because they're really really a lot
about RV oh oh well should we make fun
of should we make fun of startups
briefly RB is the first company oh wow
that's slow welcome to radars new era RB
is disrupting radar technology to
support drivers and autonomous vehicles
Zook says let's just say I haven't seen
the other 500 million of their round
come through all oh it uses 4d imaging
radar oh I can trust it oh that's all
that's good to know that's good to know
man
you know when I go on Bosh's web site
they call it the radar you can't trust
that's not even my cyber oh I'm glad you
like the lane change ooh
proprietary chipset technologies this is
joke is this I don't know if this is
tall or not
I don't know hopefully you guys the new
manager status line I wrote this myself
he's green and it's red when the
processes crash
yeah I'd typed out those ANSI codes yeah
uh what else just make sure I'm not oh
oh do we have any more orders or someone
else want to buy one there they're
really beautiful the FCA harness is a
wonderful harness it's like if true
several made a radar that sounds about
right
how hard is it to add car simulation
it's pretty easy the headless the
headless Zeon stuff is not gonna go
anywhere um the problem with the
headless young stuff is first it only
works on one car and second you're
limited by the features that are being
outputted by the stock camera the
features are not very good it's not
taking a picture from the camera you
can't do that
you're just using you know Bosh's crappy
lame finding algorithms and then like
making guesses based on that which is
really not the way to build one of these
things
skaar was good to see people
experimenting but I don't think that
that is very fertile I think what'll be
more fruitful and what you can
experiment with if you insist to use
something that's not like the ER mounted
on the screen is you could probably get
open pilot working pretty well with a
webcam um my long-term goals not
headless oboe does kind of annoy us yeah
uh we we we ship eons and we'll ship
better eons and that new eons will be
you know slimmer and smaller and have
more cameras so on and so forth and you
know for the next for the next Eon years
but um you know headless is not headless
is not a goal where did we show you the
ads where would we show you the ads
that's a question
all right 65 feet we got anything else
thank you speed drawing 101 blonde ope
on the cars compute not really I mean I
was making fun of the car people for not
putting any real computers in their car
if they're real computers short maybe
you can do ice running on an iPhone
that's gonna take you a lot waffle
makers still there
well I ship bumper stickers what we're
thinking about bumper stickers like this
car runs opus or software something like
that what you guys think what's for the
bumper sticker say um but no we don't
have any bumper stickers right now I
think we include some stickers I think
we have some stickers but you know went
out the swag business wearing a high
quality hardware business harness is one
of the highest quality things coming
eyes ever shipped so make sure to buy
your harness today can't show you that
one cuz it has user info I prefer open
pilot disengagement instead of Tesla
autopilot yeah gas does engagement makes
so much sense how long will the current
Eon be around eons pan know you'll see I
mean you'll see all in 2020 all in 2020
things will happen
see look if we had new heart if we had
if we had new hardware right around the
corner what I have a neon on my desk the
way man um alright so FCA people are
slightly better than Subaru people true
the been determined
we're gonna go for uh what is willow I
don't know anything about you know um uh
yeah the dash cam the dash cams got
really good your if you guys have comic
prime um try out the comic connect app
has gotten quite good in the last
release I show us a neon in a test car
uh yeah we can do we can go we can go
now when I got to do that that's a long
walk Opie long end-to-end longitudinal
control 2020 that's really gotten good
um you know we debated in 0-7 all the
videos the videos are quick yeah right
and though the quality is not that great
but that's the trade-off those videos
are small enough that they can keep up
live on comma Prime so if you are comma
prime subscriber those videos will show
up and your phone almost instantly from
your drive um it truly is a cloud
dashcam okay we'll let you in on one
more thing
this isn't finalized yet right now if
you're a normal comma user you get three
days of storage comma prime gets 14 days
of storage we're thinking about
increasing that to one year comma prime
is about to be really good you know we
put a lot of effort into it but those
features in tell you about internal
debates or like internal to comma
there's no debate I'm a dictator it's
not show a lot of talking about
fingerprinting 2.0 a lot of debates on
how we're gonna do that what else
no calm phone is not free it's $24 a
month bro we debated on how much comma
crime should cost let me tell you
something everybody else in the company
they want to make things cheap for you
guys and I'm like no no no no no no we
got to make it expensive so whatever
something's expensive I'm the guy to
blame are we hiring any developers we
are we are we're hiring an open pilot
engineer somebody who's good really
infrastructure testing a lot of that
stuff if you're good with we were
talking today like if you like if you
don't C++ you're on the right track but
also maybe hiring an ml engineer maybe
if you're very very good but open pilot
engineer will hire you tomorrow if you
uh if you are if you do great walks if
you're looking for a job
as C++ is it's a language yeah yeah how
do we stop progressions in the models oh
we have all these complicated we have
lots of lots of tests maybe someday
we'll go live to the to the research
team and the research team no we don't
charge money for them pod by prime I
don't feel good
look I'm not the kind of guy who's gonna
charge you money for a software that
runs on your device you bought and paid
for a new one from us I'm not gonna
charge you to use your device I'm not
one of those dicks right we do charge
you of course to use comma prime comma
front cost us money
we're an MVNO we we resell a certain
large mobile carrier service to you guys
and we have to pay that mobile carrier
money on the back end so that's you know
come from cost us money coming from also
honestly honestly we don't even make
money on comic prime because the azure
bill is so high you'll we gotta pay for
cloud now whoa whoa whoa whoa wait that
was a page me that wasn't a sale come on
come on FCA people buy some harnesses we
got we got we got two more minutes
Alton media I didn't say that I'm just
saying I didn't say that I'm not allowed
uh-huh yeah clouds for users data like
videos yeah yeah we got we have videos
in the cloud
it's like Pied Piper but only for
dashcam videos and we're really we're
thinking about increasing it to one year
no promises on that there's still
internal debate um you know you know see
people are like oh you know all I want
to work series like man we want to give
all the people great features and I come
along and I'm like does that cost money
that gonna cost money all sounds like
it's gonna cost money no not a no it's
gotta go we make money we're almost
profitable to queue for this q4 is our
highest profit quarter on record already
um and if we it's already let's let's
let me let me get you the total I'll let
you in on the total
it's good quarter today let me make sure
there's no user information here yes
this is commas most profitable quarter
today and why do I show you guys this
stuff I think I'm crazy
um yeah man three hundred ninety seven
thousand dollars that is almost a
profitable company our burn rates about
I'm gonna mount one eighty a month um so
so we're we're we're seventy eighty
percent of the way to profitable I'm
very happy we're up forty three percent
from the last quarter which was the new
record quarter four comma we're really
we're really killing it and wait'll you
guys see what we haven't we're gonna
blow you away in 2020 right if you think
if you think what we've done so far if
you thought this year was a good year
wait'll you see the lineup for 2020
things have been working no hockey stick
growth not real yawns don't use the
microphone how many aeons are out there
driving here looking rid of that
information no not at 5k monthly users
yet I'd like to get there let me just
it's an overview
I'll bring up weekly for the last six
months it takes a while to load it's
gotta hit up my sequel database ah no no
no no prime is all stored and then Prime
is all stored measure there we go
here's the weekly devices chart
so that's ignore the last couple weeks
aren't up to date it takes a bit for
things to actually like make their way
into the system but yeah so we've
reached Oh bit over 1,100 weekly active
users and you see our growth is nice and
steady um you know if you guys didn't
read my medium posts
you guys should begin bad times left
company I we just kind of break down
what do you mean do it's like Facebook
is like my sequel at least when I worked
there was backed by a single day to
visit I don't know no then you put
memcache in front of it and there you go
um the harness videos currently on uses
a phone you can't get anymore what do
you mean well oh you want me to jail I
gotta go but um ya know if you guys
didn't read didn't read this breaking
down unit economics this is our monthly
device growth see that we've really
because that's just been in two years
you can see this is actually a slight
upward exponential to that to so you
know hockey sticks grow it's not real
but exponential growth is yeah this is
if you guys didn't read this go read it
we're not even gonna make fun of
startups anymore comma only hires
full-time we only hire on site yes you
think I'm dealing with managing a bunch
of contractors come here because you
want to add value if you make a GM
harness we thinking about it tamo coins
not real never gonna happen we'll be
doing custom hardware versus Aeon vs.
tell me what improvements there automate
I think there's one big improvement but
I think that you'll you'll actually find
I don't think ministry me I see today I
think you'll actually find that that
improvement can be made very easily with
a phone as well cool be consumer and
well you know we're at 0.7 we got 0.8 we
got 0.9 we got 1.0 we didn't do a stream
for 0.7 but it is pretty cool driver
monitoring at night yeah no one's
interesting to a night driver monitoring
and uh no battery and permanent install
well uh you know 2020 guy's 2020 you'll
see
uno this balloon uh who's not real who
told you about you know um yeah you guys
get yawns man beyond this where it is
gonna be yeah so told you that who knows
and I did huh oh yeah know who know is
uh no no it's just it's for the Spanish
market
yeah it's eons for the Spanish market
yeah the comment oh yeah that's right we
got that we got it we got a you know
we're right down we're right next to
Iran San Diego is wall it's much better
than San Francisco in New York um let's
just say yeah the como uno is the the EE
on for the market we're right next to
Mexico you know we're gonna get a lot of
Tijuana sales so the comic uno what does
Tesla have that we don't what tests the
feature do you like that we don't have
right now um I can think of a big
feature we have the Tesla doesn't have
make it funny Elon for this morning oh
yeah that's right that's right
thank you go
no quiero mucho dinero por , no uh some
people on Hacker News felt that I'm
dismissive of marketing yeah yeah why
would I want to market marketing you
know think I'm who clicks ads right I
just do you think smart people click ads
what do you think dumb people click ads
right and now think you think marketing
is a good idea
oh well come have a booth at CES ah not
to hear anything about that I don't know
we can ask around that I don't know um I
want to launch a new Aeon 3 or 4 cameras
why do you need more cameras explain to
me what you're gonna do with more
cameras all comma dos o BM W no no flex
right you exactly you have an ad blocker
see even you want to sleep alone has an
ad blocker hey um what's the state of
the industry it's all total dog [ __ ] man
but you know it's not even fun anymore
right like it used to be fun when we
were punching up when we were like this
small startup struggling to survive or
punch it the big startups like it was
fun but like now it's like you know it's
not uh it's that it's not funny anymore
right like like Zuke's actually can't
raise their money all right like it's
just it's just sad yo how about this you
buy me a banners truck and I'll work
hard to port it man I'll try to figure
out for myself I'll pour it to the Ben
strip we'll get to me on an adventure
all right can we sell anymore FCA
harnesses we're sold be sold we still
won so one I'll take it you guys are one
better than then dead Subaru any more
questions I said what
how was Christmas in our office I said
to get a Christmas tree I don't think
anyone actually did it
I was doing good yeah uh forward lock
out bro email for I don't know I can't
believe I bought that car
well I lost like 10 grand on that car
too they depreciate so fast so
disappointed really Honda and more
importantly Toyota Toyota is really
where it's at buy a Corolla next year
you're here yo ah no I actually check it
out we launched a new uh oh don't get me
started on how much I lost on the ct6 we
launched a new compatibility flow it's
really nice and here we have compatible
cars we recommend really really get that
Corolla but these are all nice cars
you'll work with my I'd say my Porsche
911 2019 oh no that's too bad
yeah Corolla should be at the top we
should change that yeah I know the
website superfast I know but some people
aren't dial-up rav4 is very good yeah
TSS 2 is better than all Honda's the
rav4 is very good
the but we do recommend the round 4
right yeah we do yeah the TSS 2 rav4 is
great the curl is really the best car
you got so much torque on that thing
great car pick up a Corolla and while
you're at it bought by a neon and Toyota
bona bundle right now buy it um Thursday
so let's just bring up a calendar and
2019 December just so you can see yeah
we support all praises the 19th is our
last day that we're doing fulfillment so
if you want to get your order in
uh no Ford is over you guys Vivienne's
the only Ford we have here this Ford is
over no Ford uh no I don't know if
someone supports Ford we'd upstream it I
think we already released the code that
we wrote for it oh yeah look at that
look at that look at that look at the
line look at how nice is detecting that
line that's a solid model we don't have
driver monitoring on pc yea thou coming
soon ah EPS record oh no no no we don't
want any we're not doing any firmware no
no no no firmware hacks no firmware
hacks people externally do though hey
you know that's on you if done if done
properly we don't think they're
dangerous
if Opie malfunctions how hard is it to
overpower the car so what do you mean by
that
right open pilot it can't put you can
combat the torque open pilot can put on
the wheel I used to say with a pinkie
but in the Corolla it might take these
two fingers
um but still if you have a hand on the
wheel there is no way open pilot can
overpower you if you if you have a hand
like gripping the wheel you'll see the a
maximum amount of torque it can put it
so much less than you can so if you're
worried about that you can check we we
have we have the safety code and pan if
it's not even our safety code we're
that's really just using the safety code
of the car
um we're using the same interface that
the car cameras are using
well didn't need to be these two fingers
when I like you know think your fingers
are nice for you know pushing back on
things you could use these too but it'd
be kind of like awkward you know what
were we talking about before that oh
yeah yeah we also check our medium we
did a nice tour through open pilot this
is pretty good good
just engagements are going down I don't
really have clean data to share it's a
hard thing to measure it's it's uh no no
no we're not doing startup preview again
honestly guys I just feel bad for people
in this space I feel bad it's like
LeBron going to a high school and
dunking on the high school team that's
what it's like no no no it's not even
it's not even now it's like it's like
the Jacksonville Jaguars man it's like
it's like when Bill Belichick beats the
Jacksonville Jaguars
all right that's that's what I'm saying
um ya know it's it's getting a lot
better
what's going on please explain well
launch of the FCI harness this guy plug
it into your FCA
Yeti you know what's sad I'll show you
something sad everyone at comma was
really happy about that that a DB
analysis post you know we all thought it
was cool and then like here's the truth
so we come out with the AE B we get 247
claps I write a poorly thought out post
[ __ ] talking other companies and we get
to point 1000 claps right so like this
is probably one of the best things like
like like this is a really unique thing
that only comma can do we analyzed
millions of miles and we looked for all
AAB events definitely worth reading 247
claps
and that's the problem you got to give
the people what they want
thank you I'm glad you appreciate it
we're still waiting at this traffic
light we got to engage open pilot let's
engage I want to refactor so you can see
this is actually this is just UI this is
like UI dot C it's the same one that
runs in the computer I want to refactor
the background to be here
we'll get the vault man glad I'm glad
you read it um I want to add like all
the settings stuff to here we'll take
all that of Android that should give us
some more CPU performance launching
message queue that's gonna get a sim or
CPU performance there's so much
performance to still be added to the
Aeon there's so much performance if it
can squeeze out of that thing Linux
Linux alright 45 minutes all right add
90 more seconds we sold one Fc a harness
that's one more than we sold Subaru
harnesses I trust that they're gonna
trickle and slowly over time one-year
storage yeah yeah it's
order-of-magnitude I I think the one
year is gonna happen
performance equals more steering if you
want more steering just buy a Toyota
Corolla has all the steer and you ever
wanted
howdy howdy is the same as VW for some
outies the ones that use flex ray is not
gonna happen
there are people on discord hacking away
at flex right maybe they'll make some
progress but um it seems it seems really
complex we have a lot we have internal
data analysis on driver monitoring
maybe we'll maybe we'll do one of those
public I will put it together
performance equals more Headroom ah you
know we got more headroom led on those
new models that i showed you guys
they're huge huge models for X bigger
than the current models and that doesn't
even make the Box bigger yet we're gonna
make the Box bigger as well oh well not
for XO cuz we're reading that 18 to a
resident 50 um so you know real deep
learning models resna 50s or what uh
opening I use
they're really cute you use it young on
a Tesla yes you can come asking discord
on the Tesla Channel cool guys thank you
all for joining today I'm glad to have
you all here this has been coming on
she's probably gonna be our last
livestream for 2019 no Christmas gift
we're gonna really start 2020 off with a
bang and I think it's gonna be good see
you in 2020